hello YouTube ians i'm dave rubin this
is the rubin report I've got a challenge
Scott I've got desi do I and I've got
adam hunter who just threw his phone for
some reason I don't know why we have a
tremendous show for you and we got to
get right to it because this is the
internet and you're a busy person so
where to start with everybody's favorite
crotchety old man John McCain now as
everybody knows Rand Paul did something
that I think was pretty spectacular he
did a 13-hour filibuster basically
saying that Americans shouldn't be
killed on American soil without due
process you know that seems pretty fair
and then mr. old man John McCain this
week called him a wacko bird for
something that's pretty patriotic in my
opinion where do we start with this is
john mccain just lost his mind hey john
scott i think he has a great sponsorship
deal with angry birds that's why he
called the wacko birds i think there's
some sort of corporate deal republican
be known for that you know there's some
sort of involvement there so you think
he's getting something on the back end
he's just an angry old man who can't
spend 13 hours wait listening the brand
Paul be stupid yeah get off my lawn I
would actually like to see him upgrade
and maybe you know update his curse
words and the things that he says a
wacko birds wacko birds where the hell
did he come up with that yeah what do
you think of this idea though that he's
mocking what in my opinion was the best
thing Republicans have done in in five
years problems I think he would be
against that because you know Rand Paul
is making a lot of money fundraising off
of this so first of all he's making the
money and he's getting all you know the
young kids all excited about it and it
highlights the civil war that's going on
in the Republican Party right now and
the old-school guys who are you know
they're okay with the other civil
liberties violations that we've been
doing overseas it's just you know in
this one area they're not happy with it
so I think it's a major point of
hypocritical POC receipt with them as
well as you are you are new school what
do you think about me i think that uh
mccain calling someone a wacko bird is
like lohan Collins when a hot mess no
octomom saying you're a bad parent yeah
it isn't really he does have to update
his references and I think he I think
what happened was during the filibuster
he felt like he was trapped and it
brought him back to his days in Vietnam
or he couldn't actually get out he just
felt like he was couldn't get your
action distraction honestly like
literally I'm with McCain on this one
it's really yeah Rand Paul 13 hours it
wasn't a necessary filibuster do you do
not Amendola Buster for you know
expanding into more universal health
care for Obamacare I want a Democrat to
do that I don't want Rand Paul talking
about drugs it's so left he makes the
young turks people look right that was
the most left thing I've ever heard of
my way to you not I want to like a
realistic reason to stand there into a
filibuster what what you know you know
Jim mr. Smith goes to Washington did
that's what I want for something good
not for drones attacking New York City
that didn't even happy just reduce that
Rand Paul planted his flag could have
been a lot the return of the talking
filibuster you know last year Bernie
Sanders senator from Vermont and
independent he also did a still a
talking filibuster that was so
beautifully written that it was
published as a book we don't talk about
that we didn't really hear about that it
wouldn't didn't really get pushed
through out the media but this
filibuster that Rand Paul did again of
which he's raising a lot of money off of
you know that is something that we hear
about so I finally there's a there's a
big disconnect with the things that the
corporate media focuses on and that the
regular public hears about versus you
know what's actually going right what's
it what's a book by the way it's one of
those paper things a lot of words it is
it's like weeds in a long long form long
time Twitter all right so you I can see
clearly not a fan of this of the concept
that ryan paul went with do you to start
with you does he do you believe in what
Rand Paul was doing just the bay if we
were to forget the politics and what you
think about him related to abortion or
women's rights and gay people and all
that do you think that the filibuster in
and of itself was the right thing to do
I think it was an excellent thing to do
because it actually did get that
national conversation going God knows we
could use a lot more national
conversations about a lot more subjects
but at least on this one thing we're
talking about it and it's really
important because at this point we're
also talking about the ability of future
presidents yeah you know some people who
would say oh well it's Obama so it so
I'm okay with that I'm not okay with
that but I know people are but future
presidents will have this ability and if
there
is no control or discussion about it
then it'll go the way of all the other
things like the patriot act Adam what do
you should the government be allowed to
just show up at your apartment and drone
strike it without serving you a warrant
or at least a hot meal I would like to
believe that they're not just gonna take
out like 30 people at a time on
targeting one person yeah I've been in
my apartment I don't think that Obama's
like oh get it I don't think they're
gonna give me that no one's gonna be
that careless is what I think I'd yeah
you know but should they be able to add
guys wouldn't if they were able to just
get that one person and throwing them
out and kill him and sure why not like
all right ladies and gentleman there you
haven't we're not big on civil liberties
here but that's that they're very
old-school you know a tammy bonobos calm
is the official outfitter of the Ruben
report get this shirt use code trr 20
epiny looks calm